welcome back everybody for our second
panel this morning on urban education
our panelists are very distinguished
panelists from all over the globe once
again we'll be speaking on innovative
approaches to education that is a tall
order i know because we all like to
think of ourselves as innovative not
being innovative i think is the kiss of
death in our society these days yet
we've managed to put together a panel
where all men on this panel so i can say
gentlemen where the gentlemen are in
fact true innovators in education we're
going to begin our discussion this
morning with eric nadel stern eric is
from New York City and currently the
deputy Chancellor of the division of
school support and instruction for new
york city's Department of Education he
oversees instructional and operational
support to the city's 1,500 schools when
I say 1500 schools in the United States
that's a very very big number but after
listening to new delhi and Shanghai I'm
afraid Eric you're outnumbered here
you're not the biggest school system at
our at our panel or at our conference
among his many positions that he's held
in the new york city public schools they
include chief school schools officer of
the division of school support chief
executive officer of impoundment schools
which has been one of the extraordinary
innovations in American public school
education and I think all of our global
education leaders will learn a lot from
Eric in this context he's supervising
superin he'd been supervising
superintendent for the autonomy zone and
importantly the many people in this
audience he was a principal in fact he
was a founding principle of the
International high school at LaGuardia
Community College and created an
extraordinary innovative public second
day
a school for English language learners
many of you I know have to deal with the
question of multiculturalism and
multiple languages in your school system
so i hope i imagine everybody will bang
down your door after this eric is also
the author of many many articles and
books on public education and because of
establishing school-based autonomy as a
school district reform strategy he is
somebody who has invited all over the
world to speak about what he's been
doing in New York City I just have to
say from a personal note we in the city
of New York are really lucky to have
Eric as part of our school reform
efforts and as a very important member
of our school leadership team welcome to
Columbia University in the global
partner summit thank you
Thank You Esther for that very generous
and warm introduction it is not often
that someone in a position such as mine
gets to travel from the Bronx to
Manhattan and be introduced as an
important figure in global education so
this is a particularly nice place for me
to be this morning by a show of hands
can can I see how many people in the
audience work for the New York City
Public Schools so I'm going to keep my
remarks brief so that you can all get
back to work because last time I look
the kids were there this morning every
organization is perfectly designed to
achieve the outcomes that it gets when I
began as a student in the new york city
public schools in the middle of the 20th
century half of all the students in the
New York City Public Schools graduated
from high school of course in the middle
of the 20th century even if you didn't
graduate from high school you could get
a job in a factory perhaps one of the
automakers are closer to home grumman on
Long Island you could work the line for
40 hours a week and perhaps put in some
overtime and expect to own your own home
have a car on the driveway send a child
or two to college and those days are
over in the United States having a high
school diploma is baseline for full
participation in the political and
economic life of this country and
probably insufficient it's about having
a high school diploma and graduating
with the opportunity at some form of
post-secondary education when I began
teaching two decades later in the New
York City Public Schools the graduation
rate remained fifty percent one out of
every two students when I open the
Internet
high school at LaGuardia Community
College the graduation rate was still
fifty percent at the start of the
Bloomberg client administration in 2002
the graduation rate was still fifty
percent that had remained flat in this
city for more than half a century half
of all the students who attended our
schools never graduated from high school
so one of the first things the mayor did
upon being elected was he declared that
education would be his priority and in
fact placed the Department of Education
right behind city hall where it is today
so that he could both keep an eye on
what was going on but also a shape the
policies that were to come second thing
he did and I think it's little
understood is he didn't scour the
country to find the best teacher to lead
what is now a 23 billion-dollar
organization he hired one of the
country's finest antitrust litigators a
tough-as-nails prosecutor in the form of
Chancellor Joel Klein who you will meet
for lunch today because then and now
public education in this country and I
suspect in many parts of the world is
wrapped in a steep vested adult interest
that is the interest of the adults
within the system and the adults who
have a personal interest in the system I
don't mean in the success of the system
I mean because their livelihoods or
influence is impacted by an organization
such as this that that vested adult
interest resulted in a situation that
was comfortable for those of us who
worked in the system but not necessarily
always in the best interests
of the children who studied at it which
helps to explain in part why in a system
where for over 50 years only half of the
students were successful teachers
principals superintendents Chancellor's
were never replaced because students
were not learning Chancellor's came and
went it seemed every two or three years
but for political reasons not for
accountability reasons around whether
they had impacted policies that resulted
in higher levels of student achievement
and in order to break through that
vested adult interest you needed someone
with an eye to understand what it is to
break through a public sector monopoly
that is not designed than the best
interests of the people it is serving
one of the first things we did and it's
ironic to talk about this at Columbia
University but one of the first things
that we did is we started our own
principal training institute and that
was because we could not trust the
universities in New York City and
whether you're from this city or not you
know that New York has some of the
finest universities in the United States
but we could not trust the universities
in this country to develop the kinds of
school leaders who would make a
difference in the lives of all of their
children in fact the leaders who had
graduated from those schools and I count
myself as one I went to graduate school
at that renowned institution on 120th
Street just up the block affiliated with
this university those colleges and
universities did not prepare leaders who
were able to take a critical eye to the
work we were engaged in who understood
we were not wedded to the traditions and
precedence of failure but that the
charge was to educate not just some of
the children to their highest levels and
aptitudes but all of the children and so
we began training our own principles we
also
built on an initiative led by people
like Michelle Cahill now of the Carnegie
Foundation but one of the Chancellor's
earliest educational advisors and even
prior to that one of the founders of the
small schools movement in New York we
began closing large low-performing
schools and replacing them over time
with new smaller schools that's a
recurring theme in the reforms that have
taken place in New York the people
responsible for institutional failure
don't have the capacity to reinvent
themselves and their schools neither the
motivation nor the capacity but you can
start something entirely different you
can build it from the idea up around how
best to educate kids and over time you
can begin to shift the resources from
the thing that did not work to now the
new institution that is effective over
the last five years we've opened close
to 500 new small schools and then the
third and final major part of the reform
is we took the field organization that
used to be organized into geographic
regional or superintendent's offices
facing the central office we dismantled
it and we rebuilt it facing the schools
of the money that was saved which was
about eighty percent of the cost of
those organizations went into school
budgets and those field organizations
now called networks consists of sixty
self-selected self-govern networks of
schools where the principal's get to
decide which other principals they want
to network with independent of the
city's geography at a cost of a tenth of
what the old district and regional
structure used to call
does significantly raising the
percentage of per capita expenditures
that went to direct instructional
purposes the results now some eight-plus
years later for the first time in over
half a century the needle has moved from
fifty percent to sixty-three percent
statistically that's a twenty-seven
percent increase which by any measure is
significant however the fact that we are
now succeeding with two-thirds of our
youngsters is no cause for celebration
because when you analyze who gets to
graduate you find it is largely female
the graduates are largely white they're
largely Asian if you take a look at
who's not graduating it is largely male
largely african-american largely Latino
people familiar with the situation in
New York knows the hard work is now
ahead of us thank you
thank you so much Eric that will be the
beginning of our conversation about the
reforms that Eric was so intimately
involved with that were led by Mayor
Bloomberg at the beginning of his
administration and I'm really glad you
emphasize that graduation rate because
that in the end of the days I think when
the most important measures of change in
New York City our second panelist and
I'm delighted to welcome him as well if
Danny bar Giora he is the head of the
Jerusalem education Authority with
oversight over the city's ultra-orthodox
education Arab education in East
Jerusalem and the advancement of
children at risk and several other
municipal agencies they gave you all the
easy jobs hi Danny prior to his current
position Danny bar Giora served as head
of implementation of new of a new
horizon style school in Jerusalem a very
particular kind of reform in the Israeli
educational system he is a graduate of
the Mandel school for educational
leadership and later served as a
principal also of the charles e smith
Jerusalem School of the Arts for 11
years he's been awarded many prizes and
citations for the work he's done in
Jerusalem he holds a BA in an MA in math
and computer sciences from the Hebrew
University in Jerusalem and he spent
five years of service in the Israeli Air
Force I hope you met more delicate from
New Delhi I think there seems to be a
pattern here people moving into the
military the military into our education
systems something that I hadn't noticed
before but clearly has some value in
leadership and in promoting innovation
in reform and understanding the
diversity of populations that we have to
serve it's a personal pleasure to work
really welcome Danny bar Giora to our
summit thank you
thank you very much it's an honor for me
to be here just a minute it's a pleasure
to be here this special meeting of
sharing knowledge and experience
throughout the world and with your
permission I want to refer to one of the
question last question from the last
panel about educating kids with dyslexia
so I was one of those kids and when I
was a kid in the Israeli education
system there was no special treatment
for those kids like we heard happens
nowadays in Finland so I never had a
chance to learn English as second
language inappropriate way so now when
you know the reason you must forgive me
for my English when I saw the topic of
the summit innovation in teaching and
learning and remembered another summit
took place in the city of birth Sheva in
Israel few years ago under the topic of
innovation in parenthood and the mayor
of the city I opened the summit like
Mayor Bloomberg did this very morning
and he said he don't know much about
innovation in parenthood but he can
clearly remember when he was a child
when i get back home after a long day at
school and he found his mother in the
kitchen and he opened the fridge and so
a beautiful apple shining and he wanted
to grab the apple and his mother gently
pushed him from the fridge saying this
Apple is for your father and then he
grew up and got married and had a child
of his own and when he came back home
come back home after a long work day he
found his wife in the kitchen and he
opened the fridge and saying a beautiful
apple and his wife pushing him gently
from the fridge saying these appellees
for the kid
so I think in the past we were all
talking about the teacher and the
teacher was in the center and then there
was era when we talked about the child
and the child is in the center and I
think that today when we realized that
the process of teaching and learning
should be in the center the connection
the dialogue between the teacher and the
child is the center and I think this is
the most truly innovation of our area
concerning education and I was asked to
speak refer to the special diversity
population in the City of Jerusalem
which I'm in charge of and I want to
refer to two kinds of diversity in the
city first of all in Jerusalem like in
most other cities in the world I believe
we have great diversity in classrooms we
can see immigrants and natives and kid
from all backgrounds of such a
economical and families we have kids
with special needs we have dyslectic
kids in the classrooms and because we
believe in enclosure in including the
special education kids within normative
school and within the normative classes
we can find also special education kids
in the classrooms so I believe though
this kind of diversity happens in most
places and I want to refer to two
initiatives to innovations that took
place in in Israel and in Jerusalem as
well one is the reform you mentioned
that I had the privilege to be ahead of
her ATM its implementation and the new
horizon due to budget cuts through the
last decades what happens in the schools
in Jerusalem that most hours teaching
hours
was in front of all class there was less
and less teaching hours so the
possibility of splitting li class into
small groups were almost impossible and
we saw more and more teaching hours
frontal teaching hours in front of all
classes very crowded classes ever
actually more than 30 kids in a
classroom so what we did with we did a
new wages agreement with the teacher
union and part of the agreement was it
along with the traditional teaching
hours in front of all classes each
teacher must teach five weekly hours in
front of small groups up to five kids
this is part of the wedges agreement
they can be one up to five kids for 45
hours a week so we forced the school to
have many many hours of almost personal
teaching of course this was a side with
guide pneus and in helping the teacher
to get into this world of a particular
teaching and of course it helps us very
much to relate to different types of
kids different types of learning needs
of of the kids so we have now many many
hours of small groups teaching and
that's a great way to help and special
kids special education kids special
needs and and all kind of special and
different needs of the kids the second
thing is a is a technology and we are
closing the gaps of what kids see it's
home and what happens in school laptops
and computerized classrooms when it's
also a beautiful opportunity for the
teachers we force the teacher to ask
themselves what they're going to do now
with this technology and this what i
have seen that in many many schools we
see the teacher awakening from
long every day with from way too many
years they were sleeping and they up
must ask themselves what they are doing
now and a big change happens in schools
now just because we put some technology
or just because we fought them to sit
with five kids of they have to ask
themselves what the hell I have to do
who's five kids it's much easier to
stand in to lecture in front of your
class but this is not a this the old
story of Jerusalem City we have another
kind of diversity in Jerusalem which
refer to languages and cultures and
identities and in the education system
in Jerusalem we actually have four
different education system we have the
Arab education system where the kids the
Palestinian kids of East Jerusalem are
tending they are learning according to
the Palestinian curriculum and of course
the language is Arabic we have the
ultra-orthodox education system which
learn mostly holy studies like they use
to learn 100 years ago we have the
modern orthodox education system and we
have the secular education system and
those are completely separate schools I
mean you don't you can't see within one
class although auto dogs are more than
auto dogs or secular students there
don't meet in classrooms so it's our
it's a band and the reason is is a
political that this is a political
reasons not a pedagogical reasons and
when we realize that this is a political
question we understood that the only way
to change it is bottom-up not from up
down so encourage communities in school
to find a ways to curb collaborate and
to and to meet each other and I can tell
you we have some successes in Israel we
have in Jerusalem we have
a bilingual school a Jewish Arab common
school which I happen to be one of the
founders of the school were kids Arabs
and Jews attending the same classroom
and learning in the two languages
equally and we have few schools where
all modern orthodox and secular Jews
learning together and this is also very
important thing that happens in
Jerusalem of course we are trying to see
how can we force those communities to
meet if not in schools and after school
activities and we're making a lot of
efforts to try to build the bridges
between those communities thank
thank you I think everybody understands
as we continue to hear from our
panelists this morning how difficult it
is to run complex multicultural urban
school systems and and how dedicated the
people are who are doing this job today
all over the globe it's my pleasure now
to introduce our third panelist thin Kim
Ho who is the deputy director of
educational technology division in the
Ministry of Education for Singapore
Singapore I'm sure most of you know here
has one of the most successful urban
school systems in the world and sin Kim
Ho oversees the team which provides
consultancy services to all 355
Singapore schools and planning and
implementing technology in teaching and
learning and this is very important as
we know the issues around technology are
not just complicated because sometimes
the technology isn't the complicated
part it's the substance and the content
of what you put in in your technological
systems I had a professor in graduate
school who used to say about computer
programming garbage in garbage out so if
you put in high-level substance you make
all the difference in the world and of
course that's something that's been
going on in the Singapore school system
no small measure due to mr. Singh Kim Ho
during his career with the ministry he
took on roles as a secondary school
teacher understanding what goes on in
the classroom we're seeing a pattern
here obviously of the great leaders of
our urban school systems they have
experience teaching and learning a
physics lecture and junior college vice
principal of past cre secondary school
before taking the helm as principal of
the green view secondary school in 2004
he's also serves as chair of the
governing board for you know
tech the south-east asian regional
center for education innovation and
technology based in the philippines it's
a pleasure for me and for all of us to
welcome you here to the summit today
Thank you Thank You Esther for the
introduction good morning to all I would
like to thank the Department of
Education and New York City global
partners for convening the urban
education summit in this beautiful
customer cosmopolitan city in fact this
morning when I came in I'm very
pleasantly surprised to meet like some
fellow Singaporeans of you over here mr.
solution way let's assume I click in a
means to equities a visiting fellow in
Columbia University and now one of my ex
student when I began as a teacher it's
also here doing his master's in
education the theme for this panel is
innovative teaching approaches so I
would like to share view how Singapore
schools harness technology to bring
about innovations for teaching and
learning before I start is useful to
understand some brief background of a
signal pole we are a small nation states
with no natural resources and so human
capital is the most important thing
we've got our government invests heavily
in education with spending of about nine
point six nine point seven billion
singapore dollars or about 3.6 percent
our gross domestic product in the
financial year 2010 the bulk of which
goes to recruiting good teachers and
paying the salaries the kinsey report in
2008 louder singapore or our emphasis on
the quality of teachers we have about
500,000 students 30,000 teachers and 360
schools in our system technology plays
an important role in our economy and our
lives singapore has leverage technology
to overcome the limitations of a small
population and multiply the value of
services and products created by our
workforce we're one of the highest
technology penetration in a world with
more than one hundred forty percent
mobile phones dakari that means we are
people actually carrying two hand phones
likewise technology has featured
strongly in education singapore was the
first country to embark on systematic
national master plan back in 1997 to
introduce info communication technology
ICT by wiring every of a classroom with
internet connections computers and
projectors we also train all our
teachers on how to integrate technology
into lessons and distributed teaching
resources in cd-roms to every single
school subsequently in 2003 when all
schools have at least some basic level
of ICT provisioning we decided to
devolve funds to schools so that they
can decide on choice recruitment and
resources that will meet the particular
learning needs of the older students as
a system we deliberately encouraged
every of our school to find his own
niche area we do not one schools to be
just the same but a rich diversity with
a high base standard across the entire
system so that we can cater to different
talents among our young and to ensure
that every other student has access to
good quality education in addition to
professional development opportunities
more funding and support were given to
schools embarking on experimentation we
facilitated collaborations with industry
to develop innovative solutions for
learning and organised collaborations
organised regular platforms for schools
to collaborate and showcase and share
the innovations with each other as a
result of our efforts we witnessed a
whole variety of innovative strategies
emerging from our schools let me
illustrate with a few examples doing
andrew leung our neighborhood schools
in schools with structured robotic
programs that are built systematically
into the six-year education and
experienced by every of the student if
you talk to the principal's you'll
probably tell you about how the students
mathematics score have improved because
learning to program robots train if you
need a logical path of the buying in
Canberra primary school teachers work
with industry to develop a surround
immersive virtual environment where
Singapore in the 19th century is
recreated so that our students can
relieve history and give them some idea
how the forefathers leave in cresson
girls school students learn using
interactive digital textbooks which
allow both teachers and students to
co-create and add on their own content
students use it to collaborate with each
other conduct research document their
learning and bring about and bring these
materials back to the class for in-depth
discussions there's are just some
examples which a tip of the iceberg of
the various levels of innovation is
taking place in our schools if you do
come to Singapore and visit our schools
principals and teachers will share with
you with pride their own programs that
are evolved on their own over the years
and all these are taking place not just
in our best schools but also in our
neighborhood schools however I would
like to share one important point in
technology implementation really in all
innovations we see my personal
observation is that the quality of a
student's learning when using technology
is determined by one key vector a
pedagogical skills of our teachers
technology does not automate learning
neither does it make a bad teacher good
classroom management issues do not
disappear when you put these just
students behind a computer rather a good
teacher or good teacher technology is an
enabler quality learning needs to be
mediated by good teaching a good teacher
scan falls
students learning online and provides
guidance for students working in teams a
good teacher does not leave students
comments freely in blogs and forums
rather he or she says online rules
groups of students to think deeper
challenges students assumptions opens
possibilities just as one would do in a
real classroom discussion in conclusion
I would like to say that for all the
technology innovations that we see in
Singapore schools one thing for sure is
we still need teachers and just like New
York City we need great teachers so
teachers you'll never be out of job or
at least for the next 50 years or so I
can see thank you very much thank you so
much for putting technology in
perspective and helping us understand
its role in teaching and learning and I
know the teachers out there very much
appreciate what you've said our final
panelist is dr. Christopher Spence and
it is a special pleasure to introduce
him to all of you and to have him here
with us in New York City he is the
director of education for the Toronto
District School Board and a renowned
educator and a dedicated community
activist and those two things can come
together in a very powerful professional
and effective presence in one person and
I really actually don't know too many
people who can lay claim to all of those
three activities at the same time and
you have been one of them and I think
you're an inspiration to a lot of people
in this room today dr. Spence has more
than 15 years as a senior administration
and teeth in senior administration and
teaching and is also the author of
several books he played a significant
role in the development of a number of
successful initiatives including boys to
men project girls only and the read to
succeed program which motivates and
teaches boys to read the success of
these programs were featured in a
documentary about his life person to
person and in an article in The Reader's
Digest titled man on a mission dr.
Spence as I said has won many awards but
for us in this room today he's not just
a hero on on stage and screen and in the
books he's actually been out there in
our neighborhoods and in our schools
doing the hard work that it takes to
educate kids and understanding one size
does not fit all and putting his money
where his mouth is working in the
trenches with kids in the poorest
communities and really showing that
everyone can learn thank you for being
with us today I welcome you well thank
you i have to tell you as i was
preparing for today my eleven-year-old
daughter said dad why are you always
doing these presentations you know what
I told her I do it because I like the
introductions so I want to thank you for
that very generous introduction it's a
it's an honor and a privilege to be here
today to be representing Canada and the
Toronto District School Board we have
the largest school board in Canada we
have over 550 schools and over 260,000
students so last year what we did is we
unveil our vision of hope which is
really inspired by the words of author
Neil postman who said children are
living messages that we send to a time
we will not see and the message that we
have to send by way of our children is
one of hope hope is what drives
improvement and improving our schools
and ultimately our students life
outcomes is what we're all hoping for
for the future so what we wanted to do
is we wanted to have a laser-like focus
on three priorities student achievement
parrot and community engagement and
financial stability and within each of
those priorities we had various
strategies going on to move those
agendas forward so for example under
student achievement we've developed a
boys education strategy with like many
district
we have some real concerns and
challenges with the achievement of our
boys we also developed a technology
strategy because one of the things that
we wanted to do is equip every learner
for the digital age under our parent and
community engagement strategy we've been
working hard towards developing a part
of parent charter with our parents we
would piloted 16 full-service schools to
really give our parents more opportunity
to access schools in our community and
we've also going to be launching parent
academies in the new year with regards
to financial stability one of the things
that we had to do was we really had to
come up with a five-year capital plan
which has really had us to focus in on
consolidating and closing some of our
schools in this past year we've closed
date like many other districts were also
faced with the issue of declining
enrollment and at the Toronto District
School Board we lose approximately 4,000
students a year and so part of our
efforts have been to try to certainly
retain the students that we have but
attract new students to the board and to
also re-engage some of those students
that have been pushed out through
various happenings in our school system
so one of the things that we did is we
also hired a marketing officer and the
marketing officer is coming up with a
strategic plan to really support some of
those efforts now this year we're trying
to go a little bit deeper so we
introduced vision of hope 3.0 and again
it's a real opportunity for us to really
be driven by collaboration innovation
and accelerating change but you know as
a leader one of the things that I want
to do is I want to lead with questions
rather than solutions and so the
question that we keep asking is what
will it take what will it take for every
learner at the Toronto District School
Board to walk the stage with dignity
purpose and options and I think we all
recognize that we are living in a
different world with profound
demographic changes technology is no
longer an option it's an essential tool
for learning we've gone from chalkboards
to smart boards and when I talk to
students they tell me that they want to
be creative they can be a filmmaker on
you
to a recording artist on Second Life an
opinion leader in all the blogs but when
they come into our schools they have to
power down so we have to find a way to
bring the 21st century into our schools
because as you know in the 21st century
the work is different tools are
different communication is different
information is different kids are
different learning is different so
teaching and learning must also be
different but when it's all said and
done we really do believe that all
students really need three things to be
successful one is belief in their
abilities to master a rigorous
curriculum and that was skilled and
knowledgeable instruction in safe and
caring environments all students can be
successful time tailored to specific
student needs some students just need
more time to grasp the concepts an
understanding that not all students were
in the same way and at the same rate you
see traditionally the student has always
followed the teacher but now more than
ever we're asking the teacher to follow
the student and build on what that
student knows and can do and we are well
aware of the fact that the work that we
do really is about social justice which
begins by gaining a passion for the
plight of disadvantaged students so we
continually ask ourselves who tends to
be privileged who tends to be
marginalized how can we take action in
the classroom and in our system to
interrupt these cycles of oppression as
you know one of our overarching goals as
educators is to really prepare our
students for what they're going to face
when they leave us and in the future 75%
of jobs will be in stem stem science
technology engineering and math and it's
not just STEM careers its stem in every
job so one of the things that we've
launched is our project called steem
because part of that is that we also
wanted to integrate the arts and know
how important the arts are and we
developed this fund where schools can
now access funds for innovative
innovative projects with regards to
steam we are very concerned about the
health and well-being of our students
and so we've launched the director's fit
initiative and again this just
recognizes that obesity has now
surpassed smoking
as the number one health risk in North
America and when you talk to some of
today's employers they're fearful that
today's students will be healthy enough
to be tomorrow's workers so this
initiative really gives us a laser-like
focus on health and and well-being and
ensure that every student our system has
the opportunity for 20 minutes of
physical activity each and every day our
afrocentric school is another example of
the work that we're doing and this for
students in JK to grade 5 and this
school opened in the fall of 2009 to
respond to the concerns that we had with
our black students where we have a
40-percent dropout rate now after one
year it's safe to say that school
students in this school are thriving
with a culturally relevant curriculum
increased parent engagement and they
were also doing very well and again this
is just after one year doing very well
in the standardized assessments for
example eighty-one percent of students
achieved at or above the provincial
standard in math compared to 71 percent
of other students at the Toronto
District School Board another example of
some of the innovation going on at the
TDSB is the Oasis skateboard Factory
ironically this program is not about the
sport of skateboarding it's about
entrepreneurship design and business
marketing of a unique product it's the
first TDSB school to offer all subjects
with a skateboard and Street focus and
as you can imagine students are very
engaged and when you talk to the
students they talk about wanting to get
up in the morning and go to school
because they feel it's relevant to them
and their areas of interest Eastern
comic collegiate is another innovative
program that's happening in our schools
and perhaps it's the only one in Canada
where we have a late start which is
scientifically supported to provide an
optimum accommodation for the sleep and
study needs particularly required by
teenagers so here at Eastern commerce
they start their day at ten o'clock and
they end at four o'clock and we've seen
dramatic decreases in absenteeism and
much more
student engagement and the student
perception of this program has been very
very positive triangle program is the
only program of its kind in canada and
it caters to lesbian gay bisexual
transgender queer and spirited students
and just a couple of days ago one of the
things that we launched was a program
we're now going to train teachers in
every middle school and every secondary
school so that they can be the champions
for positive spaces in their schools and
this curriculum is infused with queer
issues into all courses in grain down
nine to twelve and originally this
actually did start as a stopgap program
but now it has become a destination
because as you know students can't learn
if they don't feel safe and many of our
students were being pushed out of their
local schools because of safety concerns
all of these programs are just reminders
that our job is to teach the kids that
we have not the kids that we used to
have not the kids that we wish we had
not the kids who exist only in our
dreams thank
thank you so much if there are questions
please step forward to the mics in the
front of the room why don't we start
dress this question how could you
identify yourself first Alamein American
Scottish foundation I'd like to ask what
the palace feel is the role of sport in
education in my era it was very much
part and parcel of my growing up
development of values etc ok could I
respond to that as that as a former
professional athlete I think sport plays
a critical role I think it provides
opportunities to learn about life I know
that when I talk a little bit about you
know why I'm doing what I get to do
today two factors come up one is
certainly the support that I had for my
family but the other is the opportunity
to participate in sports culture where I
learned you know self discipline
teamwork and all those I think skills
that that hopefully can be transferred
to other areas of your life so I think
sports a big part of helping to develop
quality character students and one of
the things that we're looking at over
the next couple months is to actually
develop a sports academy that will
really embrace some of those principles
and you know encourage and engage
students in learning thank you take a
next question Clara Sylvan from
internationals network for public
schools and I want to ask all the
panelists Eric you can choose to answer
or not because Eric and I full
disclosure have a long relationship i
worked at international high school at
laguardia I'm interested in how you are
all dealing with immigrants to your
countries and students who are learners
or second languages and what
servations you are instituting across
the board for that group of students as
well as the incredible innovations that
I've heard all of you mention already
thank you why don't we start with Danny
bar Giora and then we'll take a comment
from anybody else who wants to comment
on this so as I'm SMS as I mentioned
before we have many new immigrants
newcomers to Israel from very various
kind of languages and country and
cultures and when maybe we have many
immigrants from Ethiopia and because we
don't want we want them to be an
integrated part of our system of our
schools and classroom because I we think
this will help them to to find the place
in the society along with that we should
help them individually for their needs
so what we are doing we are finding a
balance between how many hours they can
be within the classroom with the group
for example for sport class and and and
and we take them out to help them close
the gaps and we do it now with those
hours i mentioned before that we have
now many in schools of working with
small groups so we can take them and
help them individually to close the gap
but it is very important that they will
be part of the society part of the
school not in different classrooms and
not in different schools of course could
be next yeah you know for 25 years in in
New York we spent our time debating what
language the teachers should speak
whether the teacher should be speaking
the language of the child or or English
and claire's you know an international
high school and now the international
high schools in New York
what we learned some time ago is as the
pedagogy improves as more time is spent
giving the students the opportunity to
speak both English and their native
language with each other in small
collaborative groups working on real
projects together the faster they
acquire English and their academic
skills improve interestingly at the
start of this administration in 2002 the
graduation rate for English language
learners was about thirty percent during
the initial stages of the reform it
dipped to twenty-five percent was moving
in the wrong direction but I'm pleased
to say in the last two years as many of
our small schools have begun serving
more and more English language learners
and because the pedagogy in classrooms
in small schools relies more on small
group collaborative learning than the
frontal teaching that we heard described
earlier the graduation rate for English
language learners has gone up fourteen
percent in the last two years alone and
I expect it will continue sim Kim Ho
please yeah maybe I just like to respond
to questions real quickly we do have
immigration immigrants coming to
Singapore to study people without good
adequate knowledge shopper if its use of
English background and what we found as
a school either personally it's very
important for the child to also want to
use it outside context or classroom so
even in the ministry of education
provided funds for schools to conduct
extra after school process in order to
prepare students who have additional
needs to learn english language english
doesn't come as a natural language for
not all native speakers but we do use it
to in as a business language in language
that we use for teaching learning
schools technical area sports in
education is my personal belief that
really sports is something very
important which is not just about
physical development recent I think not
neuroscience researcher not have shown
that but when students active physically
it also increases the cognitive ability
and skills and that in our own study of
students academic great achievement and
correlation with the science of obesity
rate there is a certain a correlation
that we see so in fact we are also
strengthening our physical education we
are creating a new Santa Academy for
teachers p physical education teachers
who come together to share and
collaborate and I are innovate on good
teaching practices in Singapore thank
you I'm going to ask our next to
questioners to be their last two
questioners and just one right after
another provide the questions and then
I'll ask our panelists each to take one
of those questions in respond hi my name
is Rafael Parente I'm sub Secretary of
Education in huge linear in Brazil and
it's been very inspiring to be here and
to listen to everything that you all
have been doing in your countries and my
question regards icts information and
communication technologies and if we
shouldn't be trying to be more
innovative in terms of disruption
disruption innovations in our schools to
thinking more outside the box and
thinking if we really still need to work
only within classrooms if we can't teach
everywhere all the time if we can't let
students learn autonomously and have
other students be teachers as well if
you have been doing anything in terms of
that and thinking about new rules of the
school new places of learning new rules
for teachers teachers not be in the
center of learning but stimulating
students other than thinking of them as
owners of knowledge and if we can talk
or if you can't tell me everything that
you're doing right now I would like to
talk to you later thank you
last question hello my name is I Regis
Senate and I'm a program director for
the International Youth Leadership
Institute pretty much what a lot of the
school's Heights we work with high
school students and a lot of the
requirements for high school it's the
complete a component of community
service and also a requirement for our
program in order for the students to
travel we have summer fellowship
programs in Africa and Latin America
every summer for about a month and so
I'm just curious to know what type of
initiatives with as far as technology is
concerned are you working with or have
worked with for community service
development projects thank you why don't
we start with Chris and work our way
down just respond to one of one of the
questions okay I'm going to just talk a
little bit about what we're doing with
this vision of hope three-point oh
because I think it kind of addresses
your question and and and part of this
shift that we're trying to make in the
board is you know one from we're gone
from old school and this whole belief
that teaching has to occur under one
roof to the new school where teaching
occurs anywhere anytime where the
teacher is now moving from the knowledge
giver to the knowledge facilitator where
you're getting students you know to to
be more a part of the learning process
and I think that you know that requires
a real shift in thinking and it's
certainly something that we're working
towards because one of the things that
we say is that we're not trying to
prepare our students to be a contestant
on Jeopardy we're preparing them to be
productive members of society so trying
to shift that paradigm is something that
we're really trying to focus in on um I
I didn't have time to share just now in
fact that we have backed onto pieces of
master plan and this we are right now in
the midst of our third master plan which
is we started in 2009 our vision for the
thought ICT master plan is to engage our
students to use of ICT for self-directed
and collaborative learning what we mean
by that is a really want our teachers to
look to delve deeper into the pedagogy
that enables our students to acquire
skills to create knowledge to take
ownership the learning monitor their own
learning and this list
I whole set of pedagogy is a ship
attention from the teachers to the
students and a part of a strategy to
doing to doing that is really to see is
to believe we train my particular branch
trained teachers in the schools to be
mentor other schools so we role model
for them in the training how
technologies harness to any book
collaborative learning by between groups
of teachers in own learning groups and
they go back to school any mentor and
show and demonstrate to other teachers
how such pedagogies can be applied in
the classrooms I just want to add one
thing we are built we believe in school
autonomy with creative principles I
think those issues should rise from
bottom up so we're looking for very
creative principles we are giving them
the resources and higher degree of
freedom and not autonomy and beautiful
things rise from from experiences in the
field but generally the schools are very
conservatives and to change it and I'm
not sure it's it's the right way to
change it widely and should give the
grass root that good ideas will will
will come out and then we would see
because I don't think there is only one
correct answer for that today Eric you
know I I don't want to give source short
shrift to the service question because
there's no doubt that engaging even the
youngest students in service activities
outside the school where they learn that
at whatever age they have substantive
contributions to make the society is an
important part of what we ought to be
doing with kids but I too will address
my closing remarks to the out-of-the-box
question at times in my career I've been
accused of not only being out of the box
but somewhere between out of the box and
out of my mind and this may be part of
it but
you know we heard that great education
as we've currently constructed it rests
on a great teacher in every classroom
and none of us have ever delivered a
great teacher in every classroom so i
think it's an interim step breaking out
of teacher isolation to work toward
models of small teams of teachers
responsible and accountable for
manageable numbers of kids is an
important transition but in the final
analysis the most important question I
think any of us can ask ourselves at
this stage of educational enlightenment
about what schools would it look like is
what would school look like if we're
built around the needs of a single kid
and then once you think you've got an
answer to that question how would you
build that out for all kids and if you
think about that question for a while it
would need to look radically different
from what we do today the way we
restrain and restrict teachers to the
tyranny of a kind of daily class
schedule so that they don't have time to
deal with the needs of students the way
students move along the conveyor belt of
class after class that has nothing to do
with the hour before or the one that
comes next a legacy of 19th century
factory model the one place in the world
where I think they are farthest advanced
at asking this question is an outfit
called Koontz copskalyn que un ska PSS
KO lan in Finland it's a for-profit
charter school organization and they're
designing their own schools that don't
include classrooms but that are built
around what we've previously considered
enrichment but it's now at the heart of
their educational program thank you what
an extraordinary panel what a set of
extraordinary panelists this really
brings to an end the public part of our
summit this morning I think we've heard
a lot about the challenges that our
global cities are
sing in educating their children's but
but I actually feel very energized this
morning and very optimistic as the world
schools continue to attract dedicated
and innovative educators as we've seen
here today we will succeed in our
mission to provide every child around
the globe with the quality public
education thank you for being with us
today and for those of you who are
joining us for lunch please come forward
and we have handicapped access for any
of you who need that thanks again